hey this video is sponsored by video
blocks let's tell him yeah boss about
video blocks out here we go oh what's he
got in here you have some talking points
well video blocks actually has over 2
million videos after effects files and
motion backgrounds oh wow my nephew
knows how to use After Effects oh oh
cool giving my books back or you can go
to video walks like home slash holidays
or click the link just given below or
what man I'm gonna get $50 off for your
video blocks hey did you know that media
boxes over 2 million video clips when I
did remember food that's nice I just
upload my clips and website they had he
really high commission rate and I'm not
making any money well did you know that
video box actually has a zero percent
commission rate now my channel has a
copyright strike because I didn't read
the licensing agreement oh well did you
know that all videoblocks memberships
comes with 100 percent royalty free
agreements you can use them on any
projects even commercial ones they're
great for YouTube and it's valid even if
you cancel your membership you'll be
protected and you can't get sued anymore
I have an idea a while back when we took
a the lyrics to a song we wrote a script
a short film using only those lyrics
exactly as they're said in the song for
dialogue word-for-word Bohemian Rhapsody
it's kind of like a play like an opera
and then I just I saw the whole thing in
my head got the next day wrote it down I
suggested we go with medallion pop band
ozo
my my
but I think that Queen was better why
are you doing a Russian accent
cuz I'm Russian I'm the sound guy and
then I'm also the camera guy are you
Roger Deakins sorry sis mustaches just
yes I'm Roger Deakins this is what he
does he goes for how Roger Deakins yeah
yes like you're Daniel Craig that's why
I like natural light so much yeah I will
be using a bunch of LED lights to light
a night scene I have no idea whether it
is a fight or dialogue scene but should
be about the same I will be taking this
light I'm going to swing it up and then
above the door to be in top light from
above as if it was a lamp on the ceiling
okay perfect cinematic Greta
from there I'm going to put a green
light shooting this way to edge yeah
after we have a lighter thinner green we
have a thicker stronger green really any
vibrant color gel is considered a party
gel being a party Reds party greens
party yellows and then when you get into
the softer ones you have tints straws
and taking a fill light to film up I put
a flag next to the green light
from the wall so that way most still
happens in the background what's going
on I'm gonna need you to clear out who
are you
your name
you name what
I don't like police hug
hey this video is sponsored by video
blocks let's tell him yeah here we go
oh what's he got in here you have some
talking points though I have to tell you
that the do block says 2 million videos
After Effects files and motion
backgrounds huh oh wow we well we uh
I got need a couple practice thanks hey
I'm just a kid I don't have anybody oh
well actually this holiday season it's
usually $149 but there's a holiday just
get $50 right here if you click on it oh
oh cool bullying is not funny unless its
stock footage bullying bullying is
mostly just funny Jake do you think
bullying is fun uh hey good deal the
dark side counselors holidays give my
books back or click the link the
description box boy lurking looks like
or give two dollars off of one year
video box for what I'll get $50 off one
your video blocks now this is for the
salmon you go yep channel yep yeah if
you look at all the gels that I've have
on this light right now it's kind of
chaotic there's a little home ingredient
of colors to match those lights way down
there
so that way it looks like one of those
lights bar right here
the design is two half inches green and
half orange Milou cocktail lights take a
look like an exterior florescent light
that's up top on the wall
so now that I've lived on the reverse of
the door you need to light the and
the towelettes
so we have the green light that I
mentioned and the orange like here
hitting the far our and I have a naked
light a light like edging the cop
pointed all I'm noticing a long time is
trying to give them yeah and then I your
whole arm like just to give you focusing
yeah an idea of the object that when it
enters frame since gonna be out of focus
I'm gonna burn down straight dude
you see this you see this large wall of
tape right here to this wallflowers wall
okay let's see it rack so we often take
over our street signs so they're not
that distracting the main corridor
videos many of you have a better idea
for a prop sign that you can put in our
main corridor videos submit them so that
way we can always have a good looking
sign on all our doors
sorry it's my gun muzzle flash simulator
bang bang bang bang bang bang ring ring
how do I make this REM on our strip plug
it in any flick the on an off switch
back and forth that's it it's not super
sharp in terms of its on and off so yeah
are you are you complying time flying
you like apply he's not good long he's a
compliant oh that's right oh he's got a
gun dear Achille so somebody actually
started a corridor subreddit it's our
slash corridor pretty easy and it's
actually been surprisingly active so if
you guys want to ask us questions about
filmmaking or just talk about the latest
video or share your best Simon Neko
channel gifts also if you have any
interest in prop signs that you would
like to see on our door on this building
please submit them to the subreddit if
you'd like to see us do any other songs
like the Bohemian Rhapsody one in the
future post it on the subreddit we'll be
taking a look as we say in traditional
corridor times consider subscribing you
may be hope for strangle nurse you know
what I'm in a really aggressive hold you
can go already gonna doesn't matter
thank you